Kurt Warner joining us here on the Rich
Eisen show Susie Schuster in for Rich
Eisen in Curt thanks so much for taking
the time to call in I appreciate it
how are you I'm great I'm great how's
Brenda good she's awesome
doing great holding my grand baby right
now say hi to her for me please say take
me back to 1994 when you were a
quarterback coming out of school did you
get invited to the combine I did not you
know they go through a process of
grading all the players at all the
different positions and then they use
that grade to say whether you're I guess
combine eligible or you you fit the
criteria and from all the my
understanding is that I qualified as far
as the grade was concerned but going to
a smaller school having only played one
year there they decided to pass me over
for some other guys that had more
experience and played a bigger school so
I didn't get that luxury and you know
the other part of this that's kind of
crazy is my school didn't have a pro day
either and so you know I didn't have
that chance to really showcase things so
I was talking to some guys this weekend
when we were watching the combine and
people talking about pro days I actually
traveled around the state of Iowa so
when the University of Iowa had a pro
day I went down there to try to throw to
whoever was you know was trying out
whether it be a running back or receiver
and Iowa State and I would just try to
find out where all the workouts were in
my area and I would drive over there and
try to you know figure out a way to get
in there and showcase my skills to
whatever Scouts were there so it was a
whole different process for me back then
where I think there's a lot more
opportunities now than there was back in
94 Kurt Warner Super Bowl champion NFL
Network analyst joining us here on the
Rich Eisen show I see that that slight
really held you back huh well you know
it's there's so many different ways to
look at it you know whether you know if
I go you know does that change the
course of things do things happen
earlier you know and then there's a part
of me that says I'm not sure I was
anywhere close to being the quarterback
in 94 95 that I was in 98 99 when I got
back into the league and so some of that
may have been a blessing in disguise you
to force me to play other places to get
more experience to become more of the
player I would be later so when I did
get my opportunity I was ready to to
thrive as opposed to maybe not being
ready and being thrown in there early
and then maybe he'd never get another
chance well here's what I heard out of
your mouth a lot over the weekend I'm
not impressed I heard you talking about
a lot of these quarterbacks and I don't
think anybody blew you away am I correct
with that yeah I mean they don't but I'm
also not a huge fan of the combine
because I think there's so many
different things that go into it the
first thing is you're throwing verse ere
and so you know I mean I don't really
know what that tells me because you
never really have to just not think and
just drop back and throw it to the guy
that's running you know you're working
with a lot of guys that you've never
worked with before and so you know
you're not really sure how they're going
to run routes and as a quarterback I
mean you're taught okay you got to
complete everything you know so
everything is about throwing completions
and throwing completion so when you're
working with guys that you don't
normally work with you're gonna sit
there and wait and see what they do and
actually waiting is is more of a harm
than a help because you're waiting and
all of a sudden you're behind on a throw
but your mindset is I just got it
completed so you know when I look at the
combine I'm always trying to look at
guys that understand how to make a throw
you know we saw Josh Allen throw a go
route like 65 yards and everybody's like
wow you never throw it that far in a
game I mean that's not how the ball is
thrown there's guys rushing you with
five steps you get it out there about 45
or 50 yards and so that's the kind of
stuff when I watch the combine I'm like
yeah I don't know what I can really take
from it i watch footwork which I wasn't
blown away with with a lot of these guys
that has spent so much time in the gun
they got to get better under center they
got to be able to be more fluid and get
away from the center and they have to
have a sense of urgency so those are the
kinds of things I watch in the combine
so I think it's really tough to to blow
someone away unless you really
understand how to make throws and you
don't care about completions but you
know just knowing where those guys
headspace is at the time you know nobody
wants to go out there
have all incomplete passes even if you
threw them how you wanted to you want
people to go away thinking man you know
he completed everything so in your
estimation then who came out of this
combine as the number one quarterback um
well you know I think you have to take
everything into consideration but if you
were just going off the combine I
thought just on the combine what if I'm
going off just the combine I thought
Joshy Allen looks really good he looked
comfortable his footwork looked look
solid you know ease and just throwing
the football you know and then I thought
Baker Mayfield was probably number two
you know maybe not quite as efficient as
I would have liked to see him you know
his drops weren't as clean but he was
probably of all the guys the guy that
understood how to throw balls the best
and I know people were listening on what
what does that mean as long as it goes
to the guy but there are certain balls
that you want to throw with touch you
know the certain balls you want to throw
outside as opposed to inside it and
that's what I'm talking about by
understanding how to make throws and I
thought Baker Mayfield you know showed
that in his college field but he showed
that in the combine as well so those two
guys I thought were the best of the
bunch didn't think Josh Rosen looked
really comfortable in that setting and I
would say the same with Lamar Jackson is
that you know when he didn't run and he
came out and said hey you know I'm just
a quarterback I just want to be seen as
a quarterback you know you were hoping
that he was going to come out and wow
you with his ability to throw the
football
he's got from technique flaws that I
think he has to clean up but don't think
he did himself really really well as far
as just dropping back and throwing the
football I understand that he doesn't
want to be seen as anything other than a
quarterback but do you think he did
himself a disservice by not running
because let's face it you want to play
in the National Football League any way
that you can get in don't you yeah and I
think you know when it comes to the
combine especially when you look at what
the combine is people are wowed by the
numbers right then you know again we
very seldom come out talking man that
guy can really throw the football I
didn't know that going into the combine
but we come out of it with man you see
how explosive that guy was did you see
how fast that guy was and that's where I
think the more Jack
really could have helped him so he could
have wowed some people with his
athleticism and then you go out and
throw well and now guys are going oh my
gosh this guy is ridiculous and we
already know he's ridiculous but I
thought he had a chance in those other
areas
- maybe wow the Scout Scouts and grab
some attention there so even if he was
just okay throwing it it balanced out to
be man this guy looked really really
good but when he put all that stuff that
we knew he was going to you know blow
out of the water when he said I'm not
gonna do that stuff I'm just gonna throw
I think it put all the attention on him
throwing the football and you know when
you watch him he's a tremendous athlete
and he's got great potential but that's
just not his forte yet as being a
drop-back passer so I felt he put all
the attention on that instead of being
able to showcase some of the things that
make him really really special in that
vein hurt it bothered me that Sam
Journal didn't throw I always feel like
look it is what it is the combine right
you're showing up you're sitting there I
think it made him look like a red flag
with him not throwing I appreciate he
wants to wait for his pro day but how do
you just stand around watching all these
other quarterbacks throw Kurt yeah I
know I mean I again I think it's one of
those deals where that's what people
want to see is they just want to see you
compete is that you know how well you do
or how many completions you have is not
going to dictate your draft status but
they want to see you get out there and
compete against anybody anywhere anytime
because this is what you do that you
never shy away from from doing what you
do and feeling confident that you can
stack up with anybody now I don't want
to start any rumors but I had heard from
somebody that maybe he had a little
tendinitis in his arm and maybe that was
why he chose not to to throw I don't
know if there's any truth to that or not
and if there was I don't know why he
wouldn't say that unless he thought that
was a bigger red flag then as you're
talking about not competing so again I
don't know if there's any truth to that
or not that would make a little bit more
sense but yeah I mean I just I want to
see guys compete I want to see him say
hey stack here's here's
only chance that I'll probably be up
against all the guys that I'm going to
be vying for that number one draft spot
or number one quarterback draft spot
with I want to show you right up next to
all these guys how good I can be and you
know I liken it to when I went to Green
Bay back in 94 and I was encamped there
with Brett Favre and Mark Brunell and Ty
Detmer guys that had great college
careers but you know couple really good
in the pros and Heisman Trophy winner
and I left that camp saying man I can
play in the NFL
and why is that because I got a chance
every day to stack myself up against
these really really good quarterbacks
and so I left with with greater
confidence and that's kind of how I look
at the combine is you want to go in
there and if you can shine amongst all
those great players you just leave going
ok
I got this you know I'm the guy to beat
I'm the leader in the clubhouse so I
would have loved to have seen him throw
again not really sure you know why he
didn't do that and I know a lot of
agents are always like well let's cater
to our pro day because we've got it
worked out and you know every single
throw and you know who you're throwing
to but I just think there's you know
there's football guys that just want to
say give me a guy that will compete in
any situation possible because that's
the guy want leading my team on Sunday
afternoons before I let you go let me
ask you about free agency obviously
coming up in a matter of days Kirk
Cousins what do you think Broncos Jets
Vikings well I mean I think you know I
think they're all going to try to get
him I think everybody's going to put
their chips in the middle understanding
that you know he's proven that he can
play at a high level in the NFL he's the
main guy out there and everybody wants a
proven commodity over you know a guy
that there were not really sure at this
level so I think all of them are gonna
throw their chips in now I think it
really just comes down to what does Kirk
believe is the best situation for him
and it's to me it's so interesting
because I think Minnesota is probably
the best fit you know considering all
the pieces they have in place where they
were last year at a quarterback to the
mix and they have to be you know one
those teams that's competing but at the
same time if I'm Kirk I'm looking at
this and going well here's a team I want
to stay with for the next ten years so
even if they're not quite as close right
now what's the best situation for the
next decade and you know you look at
Minnesota you go okay Aaron Rodgers
gonna be there twice you know every
single year I would have to beat him
just to win our division and then I look
at the NFC as a whole and I go man
Arizona great but I mean I love playing
in Arizona but look at that division my
goodness if you go there your ear up
against Jared Goff and Jimmy Garoppolo
and Russell Wilson you know in just in
your division you know yeah Carson Wentz
and Alex I mean there's so many great
quarterbacks on the NFC side that if I'm
Kirk Cousins I'm going okay
I got to make sure everything's kind of
apples to apples but I want to go to the
AFC and you know I look at the pieces
right now and I say which team is the
closest right now I probably say Denver
is mm-hmm you know and you know again
the Jets great situation but I still
have to go through Tom Brady for at
least a couple more years you know I
even think the Browns would be a great
situation because you have both the
standpoint that they have a lot of draft
picks they got a chance to change this
very quickly have a lot of money out
there you can make money in your
division
I like that division you got Big Ben
right now but he's probably just a
couple more years and then you have a
chance you're in the AFC you know I just
you know I think there's different ways
to look at this and I think you got to
look at the big picture as much as the
right now
you know because you want to have
success for the long term Kurt thank you
for making this so easy you've actually
solved all the problems in the NFL just
in one hand yeah right
I wish it was the case but thanks dude
it's always good to talk to you and I
can't wait to see your guys he ready for
that forty or what oh gosh you know how
I feel about this right break sex or no
more vetoes I can't wait to watch good
to talk to you and we'll see you soon
you too Curt
weekdays at noon eastern on audience